hey this is presh talwalkar
this puzzle consists of two parts
first how many rectangles are there in
this grid
second how many rectangles are there in
this grid
these two challenges were asked on the
tv show superhuman hosted by cal pen
the contestant summer was able to answer
each challenge in about 10 seconds each
given the number of possibilities it
would seem you would have to be a savant
to count all of these rectangles that
quickly
but in fact any human can solve these
problems with the superpower of
mathematics
in this video i will teach you a trick
to solve these problems
can you figure them out
give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the solution
let me first go over the answers
in the first problem there are 675
rectangles in this grid
for the second problem there are 900
rectangles in this grid
so how can we count all of these
rectangles
if you start out with the first problem
and you try and count manually you'll
quickly see that it's impractical
it's a method that's prone to error and
it will take a long time
so we need to come up with a more
systematic way of counting the number of
rectangles
the key insight is that every rectangle
can be uniquely described by the two
distinct horizontal lines and two
distinct vertical lines that bound the
rectangle
so let me draw a rectangle in this grid
and you'll notice that this rectangle is
bound by two different horizontal lines
and two different vertical lines
now we can take this insight in reverse
as well
every pair of two distinct horizontal
lines and two distinct vertical lines
will uniquely define a rectangle
if we take another pair of horizontal
lines and vertical lines
this will also bound a rectangle
and this will be true of every single
pair of horizontal lines and every
single pair of vertical lines
so we can put these insights together to
say that we can count all of the
rectangles by counting the number of
ways to pick two distinct horizontal
lines and two distinct vertical lines
as shorthand i'll say that two distinct
horizontal lines plus two distinct
vertical lines count a rectangle
so now the problem reduces to how many
ways can we pick two distinct horizontal
lines and two distinct vertical lines
to do that we'll first count the number
of horizontal lines in this grid
there are six
then we count the number of vertical
lines in this grid and there are 10.
so we have six horizontal lines and ten
vertical lines
now before i get to the calculation i
want to make one caveat
some of you will be tempted to count the
number of rectangles in the grid
but notice there are five rectangles in
the rows and nine rectangles in the
columns
so if you count the number of rectangles
make sure that you add one to count the
number of lines that are in the grid
so how many different ways can we pick
horizontal lines
for a pair of horizontal lines there
will be six different possibilities for
the first line
let's suppose that i pick the third line
now how many ways are there to pick the
second line
well as i've already picked one of these
lines there are only five possibilities
that remain
so there will be five possibilities for
the second line
so we can multiply
6 times 5 to get that there are 30
different ordered pairs of lines
but we are only interested in unordered
pairs so we need to divide by two
why do we divide by two well if you look
at ordered pairs
the pair three and four will be the same
as four three because they will both be
representing the lines 3 and 4.
so in the ordered pairs we basically
have duplicates of every single
unordered pair
so the number of unordered pairs will be
30 divided by 2 which is 15.
now there's a shortcut to this it comes
up in many combinatorics problems
we can count the number of ways to pick
two of the horizontal lines as the
binomial coefficient 6 choose 2 which
equals 6 times 5 divided by 2 which
equals 15 pairs of horizontal lines
furthermore we can pick the number of
vertical lines
in the same method
there are 10 choose 2 which equals 10
times time divided by 2 which equals 45
pairs of vertical lines
so now the total number of rectangles
will be
the total number of horizontal pairs
that we can pick times the total number
of vertical pairs of lines that we can
pick so this will be 15 times 45 which
equals
675 rectangles
so you know the trick to solve this
problem but i still think that under
pressure counting the number of lines
calculating these binomial coefficients
and then multiplying them together
is still a remarkable thing that the
contestant did
now in order to solve any type of
problem we'll have to generalize let's
suppose that there are h horizontal
lines and v vertical lines
we'll have h choose 2 pairs of
horizontal lines and we'll have v choose
2 pairs of vertical lines
we multiply these possibilities to get h
choose 2 times v choose 2 to get the
total number of rectangles in a grid of
h horizontal lines and v vertical lines
so now the question is how do we solve
the second problem how many rectangles
are there in this l-shaped grid
this is a trickier problem
suppose you take two distinct horizontal
lines and two distinct vertical lines
now it's not true that every pair of
horizontal lines and pair of vertical
lines will bound a rectangle
as you can see in this example
these pairs do not bound a rectangle in
this l-shaped grid so we have to count a
bit more carefully
what we can do
is we can use our solution method from
problem one and adapt it for this
l-shaped grid
now suppose we look just at this blue
grid
this will be a grid just like in problem
one
and in just this grid every pair of two
horizontal lines and two vertical lines
will form a rectangle
this blue grid has 11 horizontal lines
and 5 vertical lines but this is just a
portion of our l-shaped grid we need to
consider the rest of the grid
so how do we do that well we can
consider another part of the grid
in this yellow grid every pair of two
horizontal lines and two vertical lines
will also form a rectangle
this yellow grid has five horizontal
lines and ten vertical lines
so we can put these two together
to count the entire shape
but the blue and yellow grids overlap in
a green grid of five by five lines so
the rectangles in this portion of the
grid will be double counted
so to compensate we then need to
subtract out the rectangles just in this
green grid
so it's a much more complicated process
but we can solve this problem if we go
step by step so first we count the
number of rectangles in this blue grid
this will be 11 choose 2 times 5 choose
2 which equals 550.
we then count the number of rectangles
in the yellow grid which will be 5
choose 2 times 10 choose 2 and that
equals 450.
we finally have to count the number of
rectangles in the green grid and that
will be 5 choose 2 times 5 choose 2
which is 100.
so now let's count the number of
rectangles
we need to take the number of rectangles
in the blue grid add it to the number of
rectangles in the yellow grid and then
subtract it from the number of
rectangles in the green grid which were
double counted
so we ultimately have 550 plus 450 minus
100 and that gets to the answer of 900
so solving this problem under pressure
is even more remarkable you have to
divide the shape into different grids
you have to count the number of lines in
each grid then you have to calculate all
those binomial coefficients and keep
track of the addition and subtraction to
finally get to the correct answer of 900
did you figure these problems out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions which you can follow on
facebook google plus and patreon you can
catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description